die lanxess arena in köln ja am 24.8
steigt hier der video day 2013 und
vorher den große ereignisse werfen ihre
schatten bekannt nicht voraus gibt es
eines der größten fan treffen was es so
bisher in deutschland noch nicht gegeben
hat es kommen eine menge großer youtuber
am 12 januar hierhin um 14 uhr
da wollen wir das ganze nämlich der
presse vorstellen und wir freuen uns
schon wenn die seen moment wer ist denn
der warum stehen denn da hunderte an und
wollen autogramme
also wieder eine aktion um der welt
draußen zu zeigen uns gibt und wir haben
ganz schön was auf dem kasten
ja und ich freue mich natürlich wenn ihr
auch kommt ab 14 uhr hier auf dem west
plateau der lanxess arena in köln
zwölfter erster erscheint zahlreiche
hier in den link unten in der video
beschreibung da ist dass facebook event
verlinken da könnte auch sehen wer alles
kommt also bis dann bleibt dran